>>male presenter: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to this Google Author's Talk.
And today, we have Ann Lee, who is a Senior
Fellow at Demos and Adjunct Professor of Economics
and Finance at New York University, a former
hedge fund partner and a frequent commentator
at networks like CNBC, FOX, and CNN.
When she worked in China, she was a former
Visiting Professor at Peking University and
an economic advisor to Chinese economic officials.
And today, she is here to talk about her book,
"What the US Can Learn From China: An Open-Minded
Guide to Treating Our Greatest Competitor
as Our Greatest Teacher."
Welcome.
[applause]
>>Ann Lee: I really wanna thank Google for
hosting me today.
It's such an honor.
I flew in from New York and it's much warmer
here.
And thank you all for taking time out of your
busy schedule to come hear my talk, especially
to such a serious topic like this because
I know that sex, money, and violence sell
and this book is missing all three.
[laughter]
Actually, the other day I was thinking to
myself, "If my publisher wanted to sell more
books, perhaps he should have put on a different
cover that was more misleading."
Perhaps something of Kim Kardashian walking
down the wedding isle with Yao Ming.
That might have been a little bit more "National
Inquirer."
But anyway, I'll get into the book now.
Oftentimes, people do ask me, "Why did I write
this book?"
And it's a particularly interesting question,
especially for those who know me because I
had spent at least a decade on Wall Street
as a bonds trader and credit derivatives trader.
And so, I didn't do much writing then.
In fact, a friend of mine said to me that
I was the only woman he ever met who replied
to his emails in one-word sentences.
It was either "yes," "no," or "maybe."
So obviously, I was very motivated to write
an 80-thousand-word manuscript.
And the truth of the matter is was I was very
concerned about the direction that the US
was headed.
And this concern actually started as early
as 2005, when I was working at a very large
hedge fund.
At the time, I was trading credit derivatives
and saw many structured product deals come
across my desk.
And these products are what most people are
now known to be toxic assets--the ones that
caused the 2008 financial crisis.
And I had seen a lot of irregularities in
these deals.
And what confirmed my suspicions were that
I had attended some of these broker/dealer
dinners where I overheard some of these investment
bankers actually brag and joke about the fact
that they were able to secure billion-dollar
deals--secured with nothing but baseball cards.
This was deeply concerning to me and I even
tried to raise the flag with the SEC, suggesting
that they investigate this market.
But when it became apparent that nothing was
gonna get done, that was when I decided to
leave Wall Street.
I had seen previous bubbles, such as the Asian
crisis, internet bubble, and I really believed
that this was gonna be far worse in that someone
had to warn the public and alert them of what
was happening.
I went into academia at that point.
And I proceeded to write a paper detailing
how some of this fraud was perpetrated.
And I tried to send it to various government
officials and the media.
In fact, one of my friends, who had worked
at FOX Business, received a copy.
And so, when I got a call from a FOX producer,
I thought that I was being invited to talk
about my paper.
Unfortunately, she asked me, "Ann, can you
please come on to debate whether Paris Hilton
is a great American hero because she's a big
consumer?"
Unfortunately, I didn't accept that invitation.
But that was indicative of some of the mentality
that was going on leading up to the crisis.
And so, when it finally happened, it was neither
surprising nor shocking to me.
What really actually surprised me was to the
extent Wall Street and government having come
together.
And so, when President Obama had Tim Geithner
and Larry Summers, the very people that had
Wall Street in their back pocket, join his
economic team, it wasn't Obama where I was
deriving my hope for most of the nation.
Interestingly, it was really China.
For some of you who may remember, China was
a mere backward agricultural society only
30 years ago.
In fact, they were written off as a lost cause.
So, even though China was this great world
empire for thousands of years, they had fallen
to practically a semi-colonial state 200 years
ago, when Western nations invaded the nation.
And it was very shameful and embarrassing
to many Chinese at the time, to folks like
Deng Xiaoping and Xuan Li, who were the communist
party revolutionaries.
When they were intellectuals going to Paris,
they experienced firsthand the prejudice and
the treatment that was very unfriendly from
foreigners.
And they attributed a lot of this to the fact
that they thought it was because China was
such a weak nation.
And so, they vowed to make China strong.
And so, this small group of friends turned
this kernel of an idea into this big movement
that allowed them to eventually take over
the country in just 20 years.
Unfortunately, when they took over the nation,
they did not succeed in making China strong.
They, in fact, did the complete opposite.
Because they were so married to ideology,
they had many of the wrong people in place.
They obviously had some of the wrong policies
in place.
And so, this plummeted the nation into a state
where millions of people died from starvation.
In fact, more people died from that than in
World War II.
But fortunately, some of these folks, such
as Deng Xiaoping, did not give up the dream
of making China strong.
They continued and persisted in trying out
what would work for China.
And through trial and error over many different
policies, they finally came together and found
a set of ideas that would help put China back
on the right track.
These set of ideas are basically what I discuss
in my book.
I wrote this book believing that these ideas
would actually be workable in a democratic
capitalist society--modified.
But there were certain elements that are true
for all societies.
And while I realize that these two countries
are very different, there are also many similarities.
And I don't advocate everything China.
What I'm talking about are some of the best
practices of China that we can learn from
because all nations have their weaknesses
and strengths.
And if we only dwell on the weaknesses, we
are missing an opportunity to learn about
what they do right because learning can be
a two-way street.
They've learned plenty from us.
And we can learn from them.
Because while the US is a very strong nation,
we're still not perfect.
We make many mistakes.
And so, if we can find a way to set aside
our prejudices and the best from the West
and integrate them with the best of the East,
perhaps we can advance civilization and create
a better world for all.
So, I do cover a lot of ideas in my book and
I'm not gonna have enough time to go over
all of them.
But I would like to highlight at least a couple
major themes that I think are particularly
relevant in the Presidential Election year.
One of the ideas I discuss is the idea of
leadership selection.
Today, I think the United States is suffering
from a crisis of leadership.
Our politicians are polling at historic lows.
Poll after poll show that.
"60 Minutes" recently reported that Congress
had an approval rating of nine percent.
And movements, such as Occupy Wall Street,
have been spreading like wildfire.
These are very disturbing trends because as
soon as a nation, where the people do not
think their government is legitimate, government
could start taking more drastic actions in
order to maintain the status quo and keep
the people in government in power.
And we're starting to see signs of this.
President Obama had signed a bill into law
on New Year's Eve so that any American now
can be detained indefinitely by the military
without trial, without evidence.
And this is actually a serious incursion into
our civil rights.
It makes it more important than ever now that
we get the right leaders in place.
And while we've had all sorts attempts at
campaign reform as a way to improve the system,
2008 still remains a record year where private
money went into the election cycle so that
today, democracy here is no longer really
"one person, one vote," but "one dollar, one
vote."
So, what can we learn from China in this regard,
especially since most people regard the Chinese
government as a dictatorship?
Well, if you ask many folks outside of the
US, in fact, you'll get a different opinion.
Some people regard China as having the best
technocrats in the world.
And if you ask many of the Chinese citizens,
they have very high approval ratings of their
government.
Pew Research, out of DC here, has conducted
research polls, opinion polls in China for
several years now consistently showing that
the opinion polls of the government have been
hitting over 80 percent.
And this approval rating seems to be in sharp
contrast to the protests over land grants
in the country.
But those protestors tend to be very critical
of their local government officials, not of
the people who are running the show in China.
So, how did they get this level of legitimacy
among their people?
What can we learn?
Well, the Chinese have a belief that the honor
of running a nation should only belong to
the people who have earned the right to do
it.
This idea of earned authority is very similar
to the idea of a corporation where we don't
elect a CEO to the top based on some popularity
contest.
No.
The person who gets to run the organization
has earned the right through an entire career,
proving that they have the skills and the
knowledge to produce beneficial change.
And so, if you want to go work in this Chinese
central government, you first have to take
a competency test by the time you're 35.
If you don't pass this test, then you must
stay in the private sector.
And this is a very difficult test.
I personally have not seen it, but it has
a pass rating of less than 20 percent.
So, right off the bat, they attract a lot
of the brightest minds in China to go work
for the government.
And by having that cut-off, they restrict
the conflict of interest that can happen between
the private and public sector--something that
we've seen in our own government.
Now, once you become a government official
there, you then are rotated to different positions
in the government for five-year terms.
And you can't serve a position for more than
two terms.
And while you're in this position, you get
evaluated 360 degrees ala McKinsey-style.
And then if you do well, you get promoted.
And if you don't, you get demoted.
And your compensation reflects that.
And they try to do this so that they're aligning
the government's roles with the interests
of society this way, so that it is about helping
produce productive change not based on money
and compensation alone.
So for example, if you're government official,
you could be put in a position to be a university
president of a major university.
Then you must demonstrate during that time
how you've improved that institution.
Perhaps you've increased the number of foreign
exchange programs to other universities around
the world.
Maybe the number of graduates from the university
went up in terms of their ability to get high-paying
jobs.
So, they get measured on a number of factors.
And this happens throughout their entire career.
So, by the time they get considered to be
a high-level official for the Politburo or
the Standing Committee, they would have already
served decades in their nation in various
roles, showing that they have produced productive
change and have benefitted millions of Chinese.
So, many of these Chinese citizens then view
that these people at the top have a collective
wisdom that they know what to do in terms
of leading a nation--that they have selected
the best people for the job.
Now, how can we take that an incorporate it
into the US because I'm obviously not advocating
that someone must go through the ranks of
government here to become President of the
United States?
But what I'm saying is there's certain elements
that make sense.
I suggest in my book, why not introduce a
competency test for policy-makers here?
Today, the only are where we provide these
tests are to our foreign service, who become
our ambassadors to other nations.
But virtually every other agency doesn't require
this.
And our system today, where the saying "to
victor go the spoils" is more true than ever.
When President Obama or anybody else becomes
the Head of State, will have the Plum Book
where they can appoint different high-level
positions throughout government.
These tend to go to people who are probably
their high campaign donors or other people
who they owe political favors.
And this may not necessarily be in the public
interest.
For instance, President Bush had appointed
Michael Brown to be head of FEMA during Hurricane
Katrina.
This guy had no emergency management experience
whatsoever.
And yet, he was charged to run this thing.
And we saw the results of what happened.
So, I am not suggesting we replace our systems,
but perhaps we improve it.
And another idea is a thought, "Well maybe
we should restrict the revolving door."
Today, it's a well-known business model where
someone can go get elected into Congress,
or work in a regulatory agency, and then leave
and go the private sector, set up a shingle
on K Street and become a lobbyist and earn
millions of dollars that way.
This sort of conflict of interest, again,
can be very harmful to the public interest.
Another idea I bring up is perhaps we should
demand track records of people who want to
seek higher office.
This could be a great way to vet who is qualified
so that they have to have shown they've led
an organization and have provided beneficial
change, that they have shown that they have
the moral compass to help society.
Another major theme I wanna talk about is
the idea of having long-term visions because
today, I really worry that our nation is suffering
from a disease that I call "short-termism."
We have politicians who can really only think
in terms of two-year election cycles.
We have a lot of corporations who have to
meet short-term profits demanded by Wall Street.
I don't think there are enough people who
are actually taking a step back and asking,
"Where do we wanna be in 10, 20 years' time
and how are we gonna get there?"
So again, I turn to the Chinese system and
say, "Where can we learn here?"
The Chinese have institutionalized something
called "the five-year plans" as a way to avoid
the temptation to have short-term Band-Aids.
I know a lot of folks have dismissed this
idea because they associate five-year plans
with central planning of top-down and of the
disasters under Mao.
But what I'm suggesting today is that the
way they practice five-year plans now is very
different from what happened then.
Today, it is more of a goal-setting exercise
where the government articulates their priorities
of where they'd like to see the economy in
the future.
And therefore, they set performance targets
associated with different areas of the economy.
For instance, in their latest five-year plan--2011
to 2015--they articulate that they would like
to see a greener economy.
So, how are they gonna get there?
They put specific performance targets such
as, they wanna reduce carbon emissions by
17 percent per GDP unit by the time they hit
2015.
They want to increase energy efficiency in
buildings by 16 percent per unit of GDP.
And the people who are charged with making
these changes will have the autonomy to come
up with a variety of solutions that will help
them get there that incorporate the power
of the private sector.
So, they will use a combination of carrots
and sticks such as tax hikes on high polluting
industries, tax incentives for clean tech,
and various other investments that will be
very inviting for foreign companies in the
US, in Europe, to come in and work jointly
with the Chinese in order to come up with
these solutions that will help them meet this
target.
Now, the closest thing the US has to this
kind of top-down priority setting is the US
Federal Budget.
The OMB basically prepares this for the President
that should reflect his spending priorities.
And basically, they make the allocations to
different agencies.
The difference is that there are almost no
performance targets associated with how we
allocate our taxpayer money.
It is the equivalent of a CEO having a strategic
plan where he would hand over money to a department
and not demanding that they produce any results
as a result of having received that money.
Now, if we have this situation, it is no wonder
that our taxpayer money goes into all these
agencies and it's like a black hole where
we don't see any results.
After trillions of dollars of spending, we
still have significant unemployment in this
country.
We are also the largest spender in health
care.
And yet, we have some of the worst outcomes
in health care out of all developed nations.
So perhaps, if we borrow this idea of setting
performance targets that the Chinese use,
it might drive more transparency and more
accountability in our government to help align
what they're doing with the rest of society.
I guess I'm running a little low on time,
so maybe I'll just wrap up here for now and
then open it up to questions.
And I understand there will be book-signing
afterwards.
So, there's a microphone there, right?
Are there any questions?
>>male #1: So I actually don't doubt your
assertion that Chinese run by technocrats,
at least at the top.
I think Hu Jintao is widely respected as a
very technical person.
My question is what's really their motivation?
Because it appears that in the developed world,
as well as in the developing world, most politicians
are motivated by money and power, right?
So that's why the corruption in the system.
So, what motivates the top leaders in China
and why do think there's no corruption there
at the top?
>>Ann Lee: I think that it's a way of weeding
and trying to find the more enlightened people
to come to government.
The corruption that we often hear about in
China is happening at the local government
level where they are running the smaller towns
and villages, like a Foster City or a Redwood
City.
And these people do not take competency tests
and do not get rotated around.
These people stay in these towns for 40 years,
right?
And that's where all the corruption is, where
they have absolute power and there's no way
to kick them out.
And that's why the Chinese government, right
now, is trying to experiment with this idea
of democracy at the local level in order to
drive more accountability at those levels.
I would think that the way they attract and
motivate these people, like I said, is the
incentives system.
And it probably comes partly cultural.
Confucianism, which has been part the Chinese
culture as well as many Asian cultures there,
value scholarship not because it's supposed
to help make you wealthy.
The idea is that education and educating oneself
is for the common good--for the common good
of society.
If you are more educated and you understand
the complexities and you understand how to
be a good citizen, you make the society better.
And that is a philosophy that I think many
of these people hold.
And so, I actually address culture in another
chapter in my book.
Yes.
>>male #2: Hi.
So, you mentioned earlier an interesting statistic
about the approval rating of--I think it was
around 80 percent or so.
And my personal experience growing up, I grew
up in a very repressive country with a repressive
regime where the approval rating was officially
quoted as exceeding 90 percent and the president
was routinely elected with 99 percent of the
vote, even though those were basically manufactured
numbers.
They were false.
So, I probably am more cynical than some when
it comes to hearing these numbers, but I'm
wondering if you can talk a little bit more
about that.
Eighty percent seems like an astonishingly
high approval rating.
And if true, it's remarkable and good.
But I just wanted to hear your additional
thoughts on that.
>>Ann Lee: Yes.
I would be skeptical, too, if they were coming
from Chinese polling services.
But this is actually coming from an American
polling service who do similar polls with
Americans and find that consistently, around
20 percent of Americans are approving our
government.
And so, they publish these results online.
And so, because it's coming from an objective
source, I'm more inclined to believe that
and that they can't be manufactured that way.
>>male #3: So you make the case that the top
leadership is more meritocratic because--
>>Ann Lee: I'm sorry, what?
>> male #3: Is more meritocratic, meritocratic
because--
>>Ann Lee: Meritocratic.
>> male #3: Because--
>>Ann Lee: The US or the--?
I'm sorry.
Can you--?
>> male #3: The top.
>>Ann Lee: The top.
>> male #3: You make the case that the top
leadership in China is more meritocratic because
they aren't driven by electoral politics,
[inaudible]-ism, and so on.
So do you see that people in remote areas
of China, if they have the merit, like Tibet
or other regions, can make it to the top leadership
of China in Communist Party?
>>Ann Lee: So the question is do the other
people believe they can make it to the top
if they--?
>> male #3: Yeah.
Do people believe in--?
>>Ann Lee: Yeah, yeah.
And Hu Jintao and Wen Xiaobao are exactly
two examples.
Both of them did not come from privilege at
all.
They didn't have Revolutionary background
from their parents or anybody else.
They came from the poor, rural areas of China.
And because they were able to prove themselves
over time, pass the testing, get involved
and prove themselves through merit, they got
to the top.
And therefore, in some ways it's almost more
democratic because it doesn't rely on you
being able to be a billionaire to run for
office, or that you sell your soul to a corporation.
It's about you making it to the top on your
merits of your own performance.
>> male #4: Hi.
I wonder if you could explain for me what
fuels your optimism for the US.
It seems to me we have one party that is now
giving us indefinite imprisonment without
trial.
We have another that's openly discussing the
plausibility of abolishing the Department
of Education.
And most interestingly, the public of the
US show willingness to vote for these nut
jobs.
So, in a democratic system where people are
democratically racing for the bottom, how
is it that you're still standing up here and
talking about policy and not simply moving
to a more sensible country?
>>Ann Lee: I believe my sense of optimism
comes from the fact that small groups of people
can affect powerful change.
And that's why I started out with the story
about Deng Xiaoping and his other colleagues.
And even if we look at our own history in
the United States, we've made tremendous changes
and reforms, which started with small numbers
of people.
And it took a long time.
It took many years to abolish slavery.
It took decades also to give right to vote
to women.
So, you have to fight hard for them.
And obviously, the folks who benefit from
the system today are going to fight hard to
maintain the status quo.
But if more and more people understand and
spread the word, like what happened with Occupy
Wall Street, I think that it's possible.
And so, that is why I remain hopeful.
>> male #5: Hi.
So, if the approval rating is so high, why
is there so much censorship by the government?
They seem to be hiding things from the general
public and then Washington.
So, if they are very popular, there is no
need to do something like that.
So why do you think that's happening?
>>Ann Lee: I know that often comes up.
And I would say that the government's reason
to me, when I was over there as a professor,
was that they were worried not so much their
own legitimacy, because they're obviously
very popular, but that they worried about
people who are trying to be subversive to
the government.
And this is probably no different than a fear
that our government has of Al Qaida trying
to subvert and recruit people into that movement.
And so, what have we done?
We've actually gone around killing people
like Osama bin Laden.
So, I think that this perception of a national
security threat is something they view as
real, just like we view that putting in X-ray
machines at all our airports is a real security
threat, even though many people think it doesn't
work.
So, I think it's easy for us to be judgmental
and critical about what other nations will
use in terms of their policies, but if we
only hear one side of the story, it's probably
not in our position to be saying they're doing
something right or wrong.
But if, in terms of openness and about this
idea of censorship, I would say that yes,
it would be nice to see China be more open.
And the direction has actually been more open
because back 30 years ago under Mao, everything
was state controlled.
There was no private press, no information
from the outside.
And today, it's quite different.
If you go to China, there are tens of thousands
of magazines, thousands of newspapers, hundreds
of thousands of books from outside of China
that get imported into China so that they
can develop a very robust discourse and introduce
lots of great ideas from the outside.
And when I was there in China, I had witnessed
on Chinese TV very serious debates between
officials about different policies.
Even a friend of mine, he was also at Peking
University, named Michael Pettis, he keeps
a blog on the website and he used to work
at Bear Stearns as an investment banker.
And he even writes on his blog that the debates
about the currency and about many other issues
are more fierce in China than even here in
the US.
So, I think the censorship is probably overstated
in terms of what they do censor.
And I would say that some of that censorship
does happen here as well.
>>male #6: So, in the modern era, most officials
in high office in China come from an engineering
background, whereas in the US, most of them
come from a law background.
How do you think this difference effects the
policies of the two countries and how can
we have more engineers in US politics?
[laughter]
>>Ann Lee: I'm glad you asked that question
because I published an article recently in
The American Prospect addressing that idea
because not only do we want to have a more
balanced legislature, it's also more immediate
in our job situation.
Today, we have three million jobs that go
unfilled in the United States for six months
or longer.
Most of them are in technical fields.
And the hiring managers and the CEOs of a
lot of these companies basically say they
can't find the talent to fill them.
And when you look at what kind of degrees
that college graduates are having, in 2010,
over 80 thousand of them came from Performing
Arts and less than 13 thousand in Electrical
Engineering.
And so, we vastly need to rebalance our talent
portfolio in this country.
And one of the ideas I suggested was given
that student loans can be so onerous to so
many kids, why not provide the incentive of
forgiving a student if they graduate with
an Engineering degree, or some other technical
degree in order to provide an economic incentive
for more students to study this area?
That could be one way of addressing it.
And yes, the characters of debate and policies
do reflect the backgrounds of our leaders.
I talk about that in one of my chapters called
"Special Economic Zones," because while our
leaders can debate ad nauseum about whether
this policy is better than another policy,
they do so without a lot of concrete evidence
and results.
The Chinese however, basically say, "Why don't
we just test it out?"
They have a very scientific approach to economic
policy, so that it's very similar to a scientist
that says, "Well, we have this hypothesis.
We think it will do this, but let's test it
out."
And that's what the Chinese do.
A lot of the results are reported by independent
observers.
And then they decide whether to rule out a
policy at a national level.
And so, if we had more of that kind of systematic
thinking about testing our policies, we might
have a completely different economy at this
point.
>>male #7: So, your idea that we set up objectives,
measure whether the objectives are achieved;
it's a very alluring idea.
I like it, except it's got a few major problems.
One is you have to set objectives that are
achievable.
You have to get consensus for the objectives.
And probably the hardest, you have to actually
have measures that say, "Yes, we achieved
them."
Actually, "It was our policies that achieved
them rather than something that was gonna
happen anyway."
So, I wonder whether the Chinese, when they're
measuring each other, how accurate they're
being.
If you take something that was at Mao's level
of industrialization, not very much, let in
lots of Western technology, you're gonna have
this rapid rate of industrialization.
We've seen other countries with or without
very good government.
So, do they know how much of the improvement
came from good government versus just letting
capitalists do things?
>>Ann Lee: Well obviously, things that happen
in an economy are very complex.
And even today, many economists get those
things wrong, right?
There are economic models that miss many variables.
I'm not saying that that system is perfect
or that you can completely tease out whether
it's just policies or some other exogenous
factor.
But if you look at what happened with China
before, they started on these policies, they
clearly had plenty of cheap labor that obviously
were not productive.
And if you think that's the only answer, you
can still look at Africa or many other places
where they are not growing and being as dynamic
as they are.
So clearly, there are things they're doing
right that are making sense here.
And so, I suggest that if we aren't sure,
then why don't we test it out in different
areas?
Our 50 states used to be called 50 laboratories
of democracy.
Now, why can't we basically turn these 50
states into laboratories of economic opportunity?
And there really is no harm in doing it if
the federal government and the states work
closely together to come up with the right
design of trying these things out because
there is no harm in just trying out and trying
to find the truth of the matter.
So, I hope that--.
Does that answer your question?
>> male #7: I guess what I'm getting at--.
I'm not trying to actually disagree with you.
I'm just saying that if we wanna do this,
it's not trivial.
You don't just say, "Oh, let's make objectives.
Let's go measure them."
If you were gonna go try to study China and
you were gonna figure out why are they successful,
it may well be--part of it, a large chunk
of it--is due to government.
But how do you even tease that out?
Because they have a lot of different policies
that you're trying--.
They may have various ones that are better
than us.
How do we know which ones those are?
If the whole country is industrializing rapidly,
we can ascribe to the wrong factors and adopt
things that would actually be worse.
So, how do we--?
>>Ann Lee: Well, my answer is that it always
does start with the government because anyone
that succeeds is the result of the institutions
and the support network that you find yourself
in.
Even Warren Buffet had said publically, there
would be no way he can be Warren Buffet as
a billionaire if he had grown up in India.
You are the product of what is around you
and the institutions that the government have
set up.
All right.
Well, thank you so much for your time and
attention.
I really appreciate it.
[applause]